from the latest bombings that have been
happening in Ukraine it does look like
the Russians are trying to take out uh
the major air defense systems inside of
Ukraine it looks like they're preparing
for a major bombing campaign of Ukraine
there's also a ton of Russian soldiers
being shipped into Belarus and there's a
lot of rumors that Belarus will also be
participating in launch another front of
this war from the north of Ukraine so
there's a lot of things happening behind
the scenes that are very much escalating
the situation that are very much
unfortunate for all the innocent people
caught in the middle of this because
there's going to be a huge loss of life
I think we should be doing everything in
our power to try to prevent that and
sadly we have the opposite of that when
it comes to the corporate media when it
comes to the leadership when it comes to
the Victoria Newland and all these other
sociopathic neoconservatives that just
want blood and that's not what I want I
want the people of Ukraine I want the
people of Russia to to come together and
at least talk to each other